el g7 no logró su objetivo de persuadir
a eeuu uno de sus miembros más poderosos
de extender más allá del 31 de agosto
que será en una semana la fecha límite
de retirada de sus tropas de afganistán
para permitir que las miles y miles de
personas que siguen esperando su turno
para salir de ese país en medio de esta
misión de evacuación humanitaria puedan
hacerlo lo cierto es que las
expectativas de lograr esta prórroga por
lo menos del lado británico eran muy
bajas así lo confirmó el ministro de
defensa antes de que iniciara esta
cumbre extraordinaria de líderes del g-7
porque además el talibán debería aceptar
la prórroga y un vocero de el talibán
había dicho en una entrevista con sky
news desde qatar que más que una fecha
esta era una línea roja y que si las
tropas occidentales se mantenían en
terreno afgano entonces habría
consecuencias lo cierto es que los
líderes del g-7 acordaron en pedirle al
talibán que permita la salida
tú osa y segura de todas las personas
que quieran hacerlo incluso más allá del
31 de agosto también en esta declaración
de los líderes del g-7 se habla que
acordaron una hoja de ruta para una
futura aproximación con un gobierno del
talibán para ello deben respetar los
derechos humanos los derechos que han
alcanzado sus pobladores en los últimos
20 años garantizar el derecho de las
niñas y de las mujeres a seguir
educándose a trabajar y no permitir que
organizaciones terroristas como al qaeda
o el estado islámico estén en su
territorio